jetzt kommt der punkt jetzt debatte
jetzt überhaupt diese endlich debatte
auf kommt meines erachtens viel zu spät
einen punkt sind jedenfalls mit der
aktuellen variante wurde endlich gar
nicht sich verfassungsrechtlich
begründen lässt aber wir führen sie ich
glaube es ist notwendig dass der
bundestag jetzt da kommt ein woche so
ein orientierungs debatte führt damit
auch in dem demokratischen parlament
diese schwierige gesellschaftspolitische
debatte mal gefühl nach so vielen wochen
nach so vielen wochen ja also aus
spektakulären dass der bundestag so
inhalte gebraucht würden im land
teilweise habe ich ja eingangs der
sendung gesagt aus diskutiert die frage
da ist man so weit in der diskussion
mittlerweile gekommen dass die beiden
lager gar nicht miteinander sprechen und
jetzt erst kommt das in den bundestag
ich finde es erstaunlich dass das so
spät stattfindet weihnachtspause
winterpause hat man seine
sitzungstermine alles in ordnung
möglicherweise hätte man es anders
hinbekommen wenn man es gewollt hätte
glauben sie herr kessler das ist ja
jetzt die entscheidende frage mit blick
auf die impfpflicht dass herr müller die
spd herr scholz herr lauterbach viele
andere in der fdp bei den grünen bei der
union mit einer impfpflicht dafür sorgen
dass frau engel sich impfen lässt das
glaube ich nicht das glaube ich nicht
ihr mehr druck man erzeugt umso mehr
gegendruck wird man ernten wir reden ja
hier über die folgen eines angekündigten
wortbruch ist auch sie haben im november
noch gesagt dass sie einen allgemeinen
impfung sehr sehr kritisch sehen
abgeordnetenhaus habe ich einmal
angehört herr scholz auch weite teile
der cdu die sich auch keinen schlanken
fuß machen kann auch teile der fdp jetzt
sagt man ein teil des volkes einfach so
störrisch ist soll es mal die knute
spüren und die knute heißt impfpflicht
da kann ich nur davon abraten der
gesundheitspolitische nutzen mit sehr
gering sein der gesellschaftliche
schaden aber sehr sehr hoch die aktuelle
lage sie argumentieren ja auch mit
zahlen die aktuelle lage ist das
momentan etwas über 10% der
intensivbetten kapazitäten mit 19
patienten belegt sei das heißt knapp 9
knapp neun von zehn intensivbetten
werden belegt von menschen die nicht an
kurven 19 leiden das ist eine kurve von
links oben nach rechts unten
gleichzeitig steigt die impfquote das
heißt das virus wird immer schwächer die
impfquote steigt und jetzt in dieser
situation den wenigen die gesagt haben
wir wollen und sich impfen lassen diesen
druck aufzuerlegen und dann diese
millionen menschen leiden millionen
menschen januar wenige mental ziemlich
viele aber es führt zu nicht unsere
gesellschaft dieser jetzt als verstockt
als nicht einsichtig darzustellen
moralische standpauken zu halten wie
eben herr müller ist ja für was hilft
weiter dafür werden weiter dafür werden
und dann erreichen wir fragen jetzt
immer noch nicht und da hätten wir das
angehen müssen dann werden wir sie nicht
erreichen
dass wir offensichtlich im moment kein
problem haben und ich glaube wir haben
ein problem sagen die zahlen aus den
intensivstationen richtig sie sagen aber
nicht dass parallel dazu die krankenhaus
belegung auf die normalstation
dramatisch zunimmt weil dort die cockpit
patienten sind mal sieben heißt es die
herzen der bundesregierung für den
februar eigentlich erst das erwartet
wovor viele sorge haben dass wir dann
wieder in eine überlastung des
krankenhaus sie hat in ihrem überlastung
das sagen wir haben jetzt wir haben
jetzt eine 800er incidents bundesweit in
berlin 1500 untersagen einigen nun ja ja
aber ihr seht doch es geht es geht mit
optisch soll man man man man so sagt man
stürzen ich habe sie als sie 1 369 ein
baustein ein baustein ein baustein man
muss er an irgendwie haben intensiv
medizin genannt ich sag jetzt die
inzidenz einige sagen na also es geht
doch mit omikron alles nicht so schlimm
ist das wirklich so wenn wir sehen dass
es aber die erkrankung gibt und wir das
auf die normalstation sehen wenn wir
sehen was der expertenrat befürchtet
wenn wir sehen wie die konsequenzen
jetzt schon sind bei der polizei in den
schulen wechsel unterricht bei den kitas
notbetrieb viele in den ämtern die
neuwahl in dem hotel weil sie erkrankt
sind weil diagramme weitergemacht hat
antenne schicken aber es macht doch
etwas deutlich und die quarantäne wird
eher zurückgenommen sie ist schon teil
dauert zurückgenommen und sie hat ihren
eigenen bundesländern weiter
eingeschränkt das heißt die menschen
erkranken und deswegen hat es ja schon
sequenzen für uns alle und darauf muss
man doch reagieren und während
eigentlich längst in die schlacht um
einen baustein wie massive zwar genau
zwei maske abstand halten es gibt kein
mittel das jedes problem bei corona löw